wenn man schlau anstellen kann man sogar
die stark machen dass sie mögliche sich
bei walter kappacher formation die
aktuell in zürich mit verbote
zurechtkommt die heimat
mathematik ist das was uns das ganze
universum öffnen
egal welche wissenschaft geht egal ob
für die astronomie physik biologie
chemie jede wissenschaft braucht die
mathematisch berechnen wie hoch die caps
and sox hd ist eine der wichtigsten und
faszinierendsten zahlen im ganzen welt
vergleichbar markiert den irgendwer
nicht irgendwas hat ist schon wichtig
was dahinter alles was wir in erster
linie versuchen zu vermitteln und das
funktioniert immer noch ganz gut ist das
säkulare naturwissenschaftlich geprägte
weltsicht günstiger ist in einer
angenehmen welt leben möchte
neben einer menge von der wissenschaft
geprägten zuvor wo so viele menschen wie
nie zuvor eigentlich keine ahnung haben
was da abgeht und das wird immer
wichtiger sich auszukennen
wir müssen uns neu strategie überlegen
wir müssen überlegen wie können wir die
jugend erreichen bekennen wir formate
schaffe die die oeg kritisiert werde
dieses ei aufschlagen
1 1 für die transformation in ein weites
einer ökowende vorzubereiten und zu sein
man hat unterschiedliche möglichkeiten
wo die jene zu renaturieren und ich
verwende hier jetzt keine hitze sondern
ich habe einen berg durch mechanische
einwirkung die proteine denaturiert was
ist das für ein spezialgerät normaler
milch schlimmer das ist eben das lustige
dass man als wissenschaftler nicht
versuchen sollte witzig zu sein bart ist
es die wissenschaft darzustellen
so habe ich dann natürlich einen
kabarettisten der wir gegenüberstehen
und die natürlich dann versucht das
cloud zu trennen und und will eigentlich
eher situationskomik von meiner seite an
reinhold wo er das aber ganz gezielt in
diese richtung führt eigentlich noch
kein weiterer extrem umständlich
hergestellter schaut das wieder
wissenschaften
selbst wenn ich mal die astronomie
beschäftigt sich der definition mit dem
gesamten universum des festes zuständig
für alles und der rest enthaltung war
sehr untergeordnete disziplinen details
beschäftigen die für die astronomie so
unwichtig sind
biologe arbeitet für sehen sondern das
ist eine wissenschaft ja sogar zum man
kann sie auch schön reden und es macht
vorrang in der freystädter und braucht
die molekularbiologie gar nicht
verteidigen weil die spricht für sich
und das zeigt ja auch dass der
freistädter die astronomie so plädiert
weil es ihr eigentlich eine rangliste
schoft ist und die eigentlich wichtige
wissenschaftliche molekularbiologie und
die mikrobiologie wir müssen weg von der
anwendung haben als die science busters
zu einer eigenen fertigung in tv4 motto
also das ist eigentlich das womit wir
auf die bühne gehen
wir wissen gegen glauben ihm zu sagen es
ist gut wenn es darum kümmert was zu
vista sowie das herausfinden will dass
das bringt die die menschen in die welt
er vorwärts als wenn man wenn man
versucht seine interessen mit
irgendwelchen aberglaubens ersetzen
abzufedern
da kann man hier ein punkt 9 prozent und
wenn sie undicht war niemand
bei vielen kann
[Musik]
[Applaus]